hypothesis-driven research helps answer
scientific questions so we can
understand the natural world around us
scientists make a living out of
answering questions like how does the
climate change impact health or how to
get bacteria affect our organ systems in
our body
but the process is a bit more nuanced
than you might think let's take a closer
look with an example
say we want to understand what causes
cavities the first step is to narrow
down the specific scientific question to
answer for example we know our teeth can
feel particularly sticky after eating
sugary foods like cotton candy
based on this a scientist may ask does
eating more sugar increase the incidence
of cavities this is a scientific
question because it can be answered with
observations experiments and Gathering
evidence in the natural world
on the other hand should I brush my
teeth it's not a good scientific
question because the answers are
opinions beliefs and values
once we know our scientific question we
can develop a hypothesis which is a
possible answer to the question
developing and testing hypotheses is the
core of hypothesis driven research let's
take a closer look
most of the time forming a hypothesis
requires having existing knowledge
making observations and doing some
preliminary research
based on our scientific question one
possible answer could be eating more
sugar causes cavities this is a
hypothesis we can test to help explain
what causes cavities
so what makes a hypothesis a good one it
must meet the following conditions one
be specific two be testable and three be
falsifiable or able to be proven false
once we have a hypothesis we need to
test it with an experiment to do so we
first write the hypothesis as two
competing claims the null hypothesis and
the alternative hypothesis
the null hypothesis predicts there is no
effect or relationship between the two
variables being tested
in this case our null hypothesis is that
the amount of sugar eaten the
independent variable or what we can
change during an experiment has no
effect on the number of cavities the
dependent variable or what we measure
during the experiment
the alternative hypothesis is often the
same as the initial hypothesis and it
predicts that there is a relationship
between the variables in this case one
alternative hypothesis could be that
increasing the amount of sugar increases
the number of cavities developed
our hypothesis leads to the prediction
people who eat a lot of sugar may get
more cavities which we can then test
with an experiment
scientific experiments are designed to
either reject or support the null
hypothesis based on the data collected a
statistical test allows us to weigh
evidence for and against the null and
alternative hypotheses rejecting the
null hypothesis allows us to accept the
alternative hypothesis as the best
current explanation of the experimental
observations
by repeating this process with different
hypotheses all investigating the same
question we get closer and closer to the
best explanation for that question this
is hypothesis driven research
when analyzing the results of an
experiment it's important to keep in
mind that even if a statistical Test
shows there is a relationship between
the variables it does not necessarily
mean one causes an effect on the other
there is just an association
in our example even if we show that
eating more sugar leads to more cavities
this does not necessarily mean sugar
causes cavities the reality is that
Sugar feeds bacteria that can destroy
tooth enamel leading to a cavity so
fully testing our hypothesis requires
further experimentation
this is hypothesis driven research
and perhaps more importantly even if the
results of an experiment aren't what you
expect hypothesis driven research always
has value for not only understanding the
natural world around us but developing
new hypotheses to be tested science is
not about proving a hypothesis right
because a hypothesis is not an absolute
truth
scientific research is about getting
closer to the best hypothesis for how
something works
foreign
[Music]